hier midi jean luc reichmann s'est amusé
à demander à des enfants ce qu'ils
voudraient faire quand ils seront grands
bouquets qualité votre rêve quand vous
équipes qui voulaient y mettre quoi eric
naulleau journalistes et libye et on
voulait faire quadragénaire comédiens
comédiens c'était moi même un benhaim
toujours journaliste ou journaliste
matthieu vous rencontrez métier qu'est
ce qu'elles étaient au moins un veto
alors là mais fallait le bac
webb avait eu connard géraldine
architectes raymond footballeur
professionnel ah oui et vous moi me
marier pour pouvoir écrire et dessiner
sans bosser ça marchait deux ans
d'accord construire une cathédrale vous
faut bien le cas vous voulez faire quoi
vous et imprésario
ah oui et vous qu'allez vous êtes
fleuriste à hwaseong choisi c'est vrai
et vous seriez vous faire quoi moi je
voulais te chercheur au cnrs aurait plus
jamais dans quel domaine de certes
l'électrochimie hier midi jean luc
reichmann
regardez regardez ce qu'ils me faire le
petit côté qu'est ce que tu veux faire
dans la vie mais mario je voudrais être
boulanger boulanger marius le boulanger
ça le fait ou pas et alors
et toi bongrand gabriel sa pompiers
sanitaires de saint génis collègues
[Musique]
gynécologue un amalgame de comm abo gier
alors justement vous pose une question
le métier où l'on constate le plus
d'adultère en france et la profession de
banquier tallec les banquiers sont les
mecs qui trouve le plus la flore mais il
faut aussi rien il vous faudra dire vrai
les bases de revenir j'ai ramé
classement top 5 ce qui trompe le plus
leurs neuf en cinquième position
les plombiers en quatrième les managers
lecoeuvre en trois médecins et
infirmières bah oui spada mon père est
médecin il bouge pas une oreille en deux
pilotes et hôtesses et stewarts et ont
un banquier ouais ouais ouais mais
représente le pouvoir argent tout ça
donc c'est quand tu vas après